رصاصات عده رساله تهديد ووعيد ميسي نحن
ننتظرك هذا ما كتبته عصابات المخدرات في
روساريو في محاوله لاقامه النجم
الارجنتيني في ازمه المدينه التي تعاني من
الجريمه ومن المخدرات الرساله روعت ميسي
وعائلته في الارجنتين وكذلك مجتمع المدينه
التي خرج منها احد افضل لاعبي العالم
الرصاصات وان لم تؤذي احدا من عائله
اللاعب لانها رساله واضحه لكي يبتعد عن
فكره العوده في الازمه مستمره والعصابات
ما زالت في المدينه
على كل حال لا تفاصيل ازمه واخر تطوراتها
مع لميس ابراهيم
وفي تفاصيل ازمه مدينه روزاريو
الارجنتينيه اكثر من 65 جريمه قتل في مسقط
راس الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي منذ بدايه
العام الحالي العنف الحاصل ادى الى ارسال
مئات من قوات الامن الفيدراليه الى
روزاريو حيث جذب عنف المخدرات الاهتمام
الدولي خصوصا بعد التهديد المباشر لميسي
الحكومه الارجنتينيه اعلنت تثبيت 600
كاميرا مراقبه للتعرف على الوجوه في
المدينه وستفتح فرعا جديدا لمكافحه غسل
الاموال المرتبط بالمخدرات ولعل اسوا
الجرائم التي وقعت كانت مقتل طفل يبلغ من
العمر 11 عاما فيما دمر المواطنون ثلاث
منازل زعموا انها استخدمت من قبل تجار
المخدرات
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا الاعلام الرياضي منير
رحومه لنفهم اكثر اهلا يا منير منورنا
صباح الخير طيب ميسي يقحم من جديد في حرب
مخدرات ما الذي يحصل
طبعا ميسي يعني لانه اعتقد غير محظوظ يعني
حتى الفريق اللي يعني كان ناوي انه يعتزل
وينهي مسيرته الرياضيه في يعني الفريق
الذي بلده الاصلي يعني منشاه يعني مدينه
ميسي الاصليه
فجاه اصبحت يعني الامور شبه مستحيله بعد
التهديد الذي وصله
والعصابه التي يعني احددت على محل زوجتي
ميسي يعني نعلم جيدا ان امريكا الجنوبيه
الارجنتين البرازيل هناك معدل يعني منسوب
العنف والجريمه مرتفع جدا
والجريمه مرتفع في هذه المنطقه ولكن لماذا
ميسي مهدد في مكان نشاته وطفولته طبعا
في النهايه هناك
ليست شخصيه بتاتا لا اعتقد يعني احنا شفنا
ميسي لما فاز بكاس العالم ولما عاد الى
منشئه يعني كان هناك احتفال يعني شبه عطله
رسميه يعني كل الجماهير خرجت للشارع
لاستقبل ميسي وعائلته لكن لا هناك يعني
امور اخرى وحصلت هذه يعني الظواهر في
ايطاليا مثلا مع مارادونا عندما يعني تعرض
الى العديد من المشاكل مع المافيا في
النهايه هي عصابات اجراميه تهدد نجوم
الكره في العالم منير مؤخرا ميسي اعراب عن
حلم العوده للعب مع نادي طفولته في
الارجنتين الى اي مدى هذه التهديدات اليوم
بالقتل قد تمنع من تحقيق الحلم والعوده
الى الارجنتين هذا الصيف الواضح انه اعتقد
انه سيلغي هذه الفكره ميسي للامانه لا صعب
صعب صعب في هذه خلينا نقول خلال هذه
السنوات
ميسي لا يزال في اوجه النجوميه لا يزال
لاعب مشهور جدا صعب ان يتحرك بحريه
بسلاسه مع اسرته هناك تهديدات جديه لهذا
اللاعب يمكن ان حتى يورط المدينه في حد
ذاتها تكون في يعني
خلافات مع عصابات مع تهديد امني صعب
بالنسبه اعتقد انه وجهه ميسي خلال
السنه الجايه او الموسم الذي يليه لا سوف
تكون مختلفه تماما عن بلد منشاهه
ان تكون تجار مخدرات وعصابه هل برايك هذا
المبرر معقول مثلا لا بالتاكيد انه هذا
يمس حتى من الامن يعني ومن مصداقيه الرجل
الامن في بشكل عام ليس فقط في روزاريو لكن
نعلم جيدا ان المافيا لها يدي طويله
والاجرام يعني له اذرع في كل مكان في
النهايه تهديد لاعب في حجم ميسي بهذه
الطريقه بهذا الاعتداء الذي شبه استعراضي
كان يعني وليس بهدف الانتقام يعني لا لا
اعتقد
سؤالي يعني طيب منير قلت انه اكيد انه
الوجهه المقبله لميسي لن تكون بلد نشاته
اين ستكون وجهه بعد انتهاء طبعا خلينا
نعترف انه ميسي بعد الفوز بكاس العالم
ارتفعت الاسهم هذا اللاعب استعاد الكثير
من البريق والنجوميه اليوم اعتقد لا يفكر
في الاعتزال المبكر هناك محطه يمكن يرى في
نفسه انه قادر على الاقل على تقديم سنه
اخرى والمنافسه على المستوى الاوروبي في
النهايه وجهه نظري انه ميسي يمكن ان يختار
وجه اوروبيه
لا ابدا لا ابدا مستحيل لا ريال مدريد لا
يفكر لا اعتقد لا اعتقد لا يمكن يعني هناك
عرض رسمي موجود يعني من برشلونه خاصه
يعني نفس الجيل ونفس وهناك رغبه من
الجماهير في برشلونه لاستعاده هذا اللاعب
باريس سان جيرمان ايضا عرض عليه التجديد
وهو يف الان عائله ميسي مرتاحه للعيش في
باريس يمكن ان يكون هذا امر يعني يرجع كفه
باريس سان جيرمان لكن في النهايه ميسي
يفكر في الاستثمار المادي لانه اليوم يعلم
جيدا في نهايه مسيره الاسم يعني له قيمه
كبيره لا ننسى ايضا ان هناك عروض حتى من
السعوديه وعروض يعني جديه يمكن ان
نكتشفها خلال الفتره المقبله لكن خلال
زياره ميسي السياحيه للمملكه اعتقد سوف
تكشف بعض الملامح عن وجهه ميسي ليس الموسم
المقبل ممكن الموسم الذي يليه يمكن ان
المملكه تجمع بين كريستيانو رونالدو وميسي
في لا احد يعلم طبعا القريب يحمل الكثير
على كل حال نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر الرياضي
شكرا لك شكرا